do you think you would take up jiu-jitsu
in your 40s if you had been introduced
to something else in your 20s like Muay
Thai boxing etc I'm struggling with
jujitsu I respect the hell out out of it
I have an easier time with boxing and
kickboxing I'm just like I have an
easier time with these things yeah yeah
yeah so that's what I'm gonna focus on
yeah giving your most recent admission
that you're you are boring obviously
you're not because of your popularity do
you think you'd pick it up later in life
Jiu Jitsu
to me is the chor boxing kickboxing is
fun I think because in my youth I
figured out how to move my body in that
way I'm 43 by the way so first of all do
I think I would go to jujitsu or start
jujitsu or get into jujitsu in my 40s if
I hadn't if I had been yes absolutely
understand the power of jujitsu is very
real the real thing
and once I recognized it I wanted to
have that power the power to choke
people arm lock them dominate win like
win with no mercy now what what's
interesting about this is there's
certain people like certain things right
and he even says like I have an easier
time with kickboxing and boxing cuz he's
be part of that's cuz he's done it for a
long time since it's 20 so this just
easy for him and it like jiu-jitsu seems
like a chore for him because you know
what else he's getting beat up you know
if he doesn't just get into it now he's
getting beat up he's getting yeah that's
a chore man it's hard it's hard on the
ego yeah yeah I thought of an
interesting rule if you don't like
jiu-jitsu if you don't think you liked
you maybe you what do you think of this
rule if you don't think you like
jiu-jitsu take it and I'll try to think
could take it for six months take it for
three months and I said take it until
you legitimately submit someone that is
comparable in some way to you yeah you
think that's a good rule I think that's
a good rule yeah yeah because I'm not
talking about you you tapped someone out
that's weak and small or weaker
than you and smaller than you and then
you like see I can tap mine I'm gonna
quit now no I'm talking about someone
that's equivalent to someone that has
some comparable like physical attributes
to you because I believe that once
somebody gets the taste of the pain and
also this if this also implies or if
actually if you train enough that you
submit someone that means you got
submitted Oh
thousand probably five hundred times you
think that's a good number
I bet if you by the time you submit one
someone in jujitsu you've probably been
submitted five hundred times
okay 410 three hundred times three
hundred times yeah yeah if you go to a
jiu-jitsu Academy as a white belt is
zero training yeah yeah you're gonna get
submitted four times five times six
times a class mm-hmm right
well it just depends if there's other
white belts that that are first second
third 450 first month so you could know
yeah you could depend being submitted
yeah oh yeah it's for 300 it's two
hundred times it's definitely more than
one hundred but I wouldn't say be here
attempt on a hundred times in a week
wait before you it was before we talk
about anybody yes yeah that that's gonna
depend if you have other white belt in
first day guys let's say you've yeah of
course you know you've been training for
three weeks you can tap out something
that hasn't been trained again yeah yeah
that's that's how fast you can learn
jujitsu yeah when I for the first moves
that I learned I didn't I probably knew
like a month's worth of jujitsu but no
one could hang with me because I knew
like the basic start and no one even
knew what to do yeah yeah consider a
rear naked choke all you have to do is
you can learn the rear naked choke one
day in the beginning of class and all
you have to figure out when you roll if
a guy doesn't have much experience all
you have to figure out is how to get on
his back it's all you got it's really
cool when you teach kids jujitsu like
you can say something like you could
give them the class on how to pass the
guard Yeah right and they would start to
do what you told them to do or you could
say okay your goal is to get out of
their legs and get around and they'll
figure out how to do it yeah and it's
pretty awesome yeah and then what you do
is you give a couple little pointers
yeah
because their instincts will be a little
bit off but you came a couple little
pointers a couple things to work with
and then they'll develop those into some
really cool yeah it's and I don't know
if I said this before but that even is
true
not as much but it's still true with
adults yeah it's because if you teach
them the technique first and then then
you say hey those techniques I taught
you that's passing the garden and it
doesn't it's way easier to like get it's
almost like getting a big piece of clay
and being like okay make the head make
the body make the arms that's it and
then me like okay now you've got the
arms that's cool now I'll make the
fingers now I make the you know and then
start to go with the details there as
far as the technical techniques with
like passing the guard but I that's how
actually that's how I learned from Dean
where he would teach stuff but I would
just see him like getting passed and I
know okay when he gets passed you that's
like hard to get out of so that's what I
wanted to try to do and when guys would
get that affirmative yeah so it it I
thought I thought that it really worked
better that way too just to teach that
way if someone's starting from zero yeah
because it's hard to put into context
when you don't know anything you're like
yeah I'm doing this cool like pretty
cool me it's fun doing the intro class
at the muster cuz you have a lot of
people that have never done jujitsu yeah
yeah yeah and we that's that like how
and how you're saying to teach is
exactly how we teach meals like hey this
is the concept and then we teach a
couple little moves of like what to do
there and then you watch people get
after it and they do get better it's
pretty cool yeah but yes here the the
reason for this this goes for anything
by the way if you are successful
especially if they're all if they're
kind of similar like in this case where
he's like okay martial arts right
jiu-jitsu I'm gonna start jiu-jitsu way
late meanwhile I have experience doing
Muay Thai boxing so if he has experience
assuming he's been somewhat successful
not necessarily in competition but not
not competition just so he knows what
he's doing when he throws a punch he can
have a level of success of that punch
landing you know like and it's gonna be
pretty often if he has 20 years
experience ki particular so he's
experiencing little little micro
successes when he jumps in the boxing
situation on wait time and jiu-jitsu is
getting failures all day all day it's a
huge chore and that's
like so if you look if you're if you're
going in with nothing
you have no micro the you know successes
no nothing you're just going in I don't
train anything I go in sure I'll take
some hits I'll take some failures
because I'm learning this new thing but
if you have it compared to look I'm
gonna come into victory MMA I'm gonna
see the kickboxing situation going on
say you Jitsu situation going on
my brain is automatically gonna be like
okay what's gonna be the best experience
for me right micro victories I'm gonna
go where the victories are I'm gonna go
where the payoff is you know those
payoffs where I can land punches I can
do it I can know what I'm doing dang
when I move my body it does what I want
it to do and it yields success yeah it's
effective or I can go to jiu-jitsu and
where everyone else has success everyone
else is getting their payoff not me by
the way everyone else is I'm getting
tapped out and that Park in and of
itself is like that's it especially if
your guidance is it a personality thing
where some people as soon as they get as
soon as they get tapped in jujitsu or
like oh my god I need to learn this
immediately like you know when you young
people get the jujitsu bug yeah sure
yeah everyone that's the jujitsu bug
right
not everyone a lot of people do well
what percentage of people get the
jujitsu book 20% 30% depends like 20% of
who of all-star human being yeah it's
probably not even 20% yeah think about
it it's weird as much as there's there
is
jiu-jitsu as much as we talk about it in
a very positive way people normal people
have a hard time with it it's weird for
me to admit that it's weird for me to
say that be but if I think about it I've
talked about this before like of all the
people that I've introduced to Jesus ooh
over the years mm-hmm
I would I think I have like maybe four
black belts of people that I fully like
they started you did too because of me
I'm talking so that with those
percentages it's very very small people
that actually stick with it get the bug
yeah and but you and you can get the bug
and the bug kind of wear off you know
how that is where you know I I remember
then that's not the bug that's not the
real bug that's like the diet
some bug light because people gets
purple belt and then they don't show up
anymore because that roundup they don't
show people who Belton they don't show
up anymore yeah yeah just just and
there's people get off keep training
yeah
basket bug that's yeah go bug yeah fully
I you think like when you dream about it
you know like you dream you'll learn
live and you'll dream up it'll just kind
of be a new thing in your mind you know
content in the subconscious I thought
that that was kind of it but in my
experience that that goes away sometime
it depends on what you're into mmm but I
don't know yeah but nonetheless he
that's it that's what I think
cuz that's pretty common like yes there
sure in this was like an actual advice
yeah like you think you yeah I was there
so my answers are yes I would have done
jiu-jitsu because I would have had the
bug and my advice is if it's a chore
keep doing it now it's fun yeah it is
fun to get beat it's fun to get like
it's fun it's it's fun to have like my
favorite people to train with other
people that gave me the hardest runs
yeah and I might absolute most favorite
people to train with other people I
actually can get me you know but it's
again we you have to have this there's
this third factor here where the
kickboxing and boxing is right there I
could be right there right now and in
winning you know just doing it and but
I'm not I'm over here in this guy's
mounted on me and in he's yeah he's
choking me and stuff like it's man it's
I dig it man
it makes her I guess we could reverse
this question say like okay Jacqueline
when why why aren't you in boxing and
striking all the time for me that's a
pretty it's actually not that hard of an
answer I've done boxing and striking and
the thing that is different is in boxing
and striking even though you're talking
about micro wins most of the nights of
training boxing or kickboxing they're
the micro wins are against pads in a bag
yeah right because you're not sparring
every night and if you are sparring
every night you're making a mistake
yeah and you're not even going as hard
and you're not comparatively yeah yeah I
mean you can have fun
we do that too like we call it playing
tag where you're like you're like
touching the person you're it's almost
like a slap fight you know but you can't
do that ever you can't spar every night
and you should inspire every night if
you are sparring every night you're
wrong but you can roll every night yeah
you can get mmm but you can get full
victories not micro victories full
submissions yeah you know yeah yeah and
I agree and I think that if you did say
it really depends on who you are but to
me that was the the big time appeal and
still is the the legitimate appeal of
jiu-jitsu where you know like people
even now they'll be like hey but this
martial arts is superior because this
and that but really just kind of being
tested the best because you're going
against us introduce people speak enemy
enemy quote unquote enemy yes it sounds
funny when people are like how would you
ever get someone's arm there they're
like oh yeah you get the good eat that
arm lock try that on me it's like okay
cool yeah was I just reading about but
didn't um
Gordon Ryan just beat somebody he like
called it yeah he called it middle more
seven yeah he was like I'm gonna beat
you with this and he did it within this
amount of time did it that's by the way
it yeah and that's how it is man and
that's against a high level guy will go
drains obviously one of the best guys
right now um but that that is kind of
how did you do is you know unless it's
like so that's huge giant like football
player just spazzing and writing away
the whole time if you're someone
engaging you that's kind of how it is
where you're like oh I can choke if they
don't know dude it's and you know yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah for sure
they're like just get my arm there but
and Ryan did not do that to someone that
didn't know jujitsu I know holy and
that's the funny because that's those
those are the Hixton stories you know
like Hickson would be like I'm gonna
every all of you 14 black belts I'm
gonna arm lock your left arm all of you
and he'd do it all of them black belts
yeah yeah that the you heard those
stories right yeah I rolled with Hickson
I've talked about that before yeah Hicks
is really good at jujitsu
yeah but yes but not uno though so
what'd he do though like what what do
you know no no my advice is a like I
said that's why I think my new rule is
train until you submit someone that is
legitimately comparable to you and then
if you don't like it still then don't
train like I there was one guy on social
media that like kept coming back to me
like I know I hate jiu-jitsu yeah I hate
it I hate it I was like after a while
I'm like okay can you defend yourself
against you know a takedown can you get
up from the bottom okay didn't go find
something else to do and quit
complaining to me about it like everyone
has not been for jiu-jitsu I get it yeah
fine
yeah but it still is beneficial though
feels like it is for that's what it
feels like that's what I'm saying that's
what feels like to you and Mia and to
the people that we hang out with and
that's why when I was saying like some
people don't like jiu-jitsu it's really
weird for me yeah to understand that I
have a hard time with their perspective
yeah I mean that's mr. mr. understand
their perspective tell me like I don't
like to did so it's like a why why would
you not like it
glad you don't like it makes life easier
for me one person I'll have to worry
about being able to choke me I would say
this try this if you're in this
situation this is what I would do try to
forget about but like when you're like
okay I'm gonna go jiu-jitsu tonight
forget about boxing as a concept forget
about kickbox forget about it like don't
don't think about that you're like your
whole thing right now is like it's just
jiu-jitsu and learn or think of it as
like just this complete learning
experience of course but forget about
the boxing because anytime like that's
how that's what's gonna happen when you
keep that boxing on your mind or they
keep boxing on your mind you're like why
am i doing this when I could be doing
boxing which is like badass anyway you
know kind of thing but just forget about
it yeah I think that's the thing you
know how like guys in the UFC that'll
that'll happen sometimes where they're
super good at jiu-jitsu and then the
trained boxing yeah and it's vice-versa
- yeah yeah yeah like I was just saying
like some people and and this is true
with fighters some fighters don't like
striking they don't like to get hit
specifically no one Minds punching
people some people like it
some people like they truly like to
punch someone else in the head some
people are good with it most people are
good with it cuz it feels good
some people don't like to get hit they
really don't like that some people don't
like to get smashed on the ground they
get claustrophobic right they don't like
that
and so different people have a little
different I don't have calm weaknesses
but preferences yeah and you can see
that very clearly especially in the
earlier ufc's nowadays you're not
getting the UFC if you're super
uncomfortable in in any arena of martial
arts yeah if you're just if you're just
super uncomfortable stand up you you
know maybe you might make an undercard
barely but you don't see that oh yeah
sure I like that rule until you tap
someone oh yeah like legit
yeah comparable to you because what I
think happens once you do that you're
like yeah yeah and you got the benefit
of getting tapped out which is a bat
which to me motivates me more than just
tapping someone out yeah how did someone
control me think about that another
human being can control me completely
yeah Dean does that to me sometimes I'm
sitting here thinking to myself I'm like
man I've been training for a really long
time and I'm a grown man yeah in good
physical condition relatively strong and
he can hold me in a position where I
cannot do anything and I can actually do
that to him to not as clearly not as
often yeah but like we he's got he's got
three positions he can do it to me and I
think he can cross side-mount
and on all fours right oh if I'm in one
of those positions or he's one of those
positions on me yeah I'm doomed a deal
for me it's only I don't have mountain
on him but his Mount Escape is awesome
and my mounts not really good so he's he
can get out of that so it's no big deal
but cross-eyed or when he's on all fours
I'm gonna torture him and we both know
we're gonna get tortured in those
positions for him it's too pitiful for
him me there's two positions he's gonna
get tortured him for me there's three
positions I'm gonna get tortured and
tortured yeah tortured yes sir you've
seen it yeah yeah torture yeah you felt
it too all both examples except amount
like in escape mode you have good oh
yeah no man
yeah yeah thank you escape notice but
yeah no that's bad I dig it
that isn't that weird oh you have you
know 25 over 25 years experience train
very strong and big by the way like
compared to like a normal jiu-jitsu guy
like you're a big Europe thing this huge
plain jiu-jitsu player and big strong
experience know what to do know what not
to do all that doesn't mean anything
gets for that moment doesn't mean
nothing yeah
holy cow yeah that scary thing yeah